here's a tip if you're a woman and you
don't want to be noticed by men if
indeed even the brief glance of a man
offends you and causes trauma then you
might consider wearing clothing when you
go out in public
now I'm not saying you need to cover
yourself in a burlap sack or hit the gym
in a parka and snow pants but I am
saying that you probably want to wear
more than just your underwear women are
working out in skimpy spandex shorts and
a sports bra a uniform that has become
by the way quite common at gyms all
across the country at some point in the
past few years the nation's women
decided by majority vote I guess that
clothes are optional when working out in
public and yeah according to the laws in
most States apparently they're free to
treat the gym like a nudist resort if
they so choose but they're not free to
control everyone else's minds and
eyeballs while they perform a striptease
at Planet Fitness the woman in the
second video she actually strips down to
her underwear in the middle of the gym
they have locker rooms for that purpose
but she chose to do it in public perhaps
next she'll give herself a sponge bath
while standing on the treadmill I mean
who knows